[Music]
thank you
hello and welcome to the week in 60
minutes brought to you by spectator TV
on this April the 27th my name is
Freddie gray I am the deputyator of The
Spectator and I will be your host today
coming up the Stormtroopers our cover
piece this week is about kirst Armor's
New Model Army of centrists who are
slowly taking over the party again
taking back control as Katie bull says
in her cover fees I'll be joined by
Katie Bulls that's our political editor
and the broadcaster and times radio host
and former labor advisor in fact Aisha
hazarika
next we'll go to Africa and Sudan where
a civil war is has broken out in cartoon
I'll be joined by Dr Chirino hitting fuo
who is a former minister in south of
Sudan
to discuss the escalating conflict
and from Africa to America Joe Biden the
president of the United States has
announced that he will indeed be running
again in 2024 for re-election I'll be
joined by the broadcaster Grace Curley
to discuss what that means how unpopular
or popular it is not very easy answer
and we'll also talk about the Republican
side of the equation with the looming
fight between Ron DeSantis the governor
of Florida and of course Donald J Trump
and last of all we'll talk about Hamlet
the play there is another play called
the motive in the queue about Hamlet and
a very famous production
of Hamlet directed by John gilgood and
starring Richard Burton and we'll be
discussing that with Robert galacton the
male theater critic and the director
Sean Matthias
now if you like spectator TV and I'm
sure that you do you should subscribe to
our YouTube channel and you can do that
by hitting the Subscribe button at the
bottom of your screen and the bell icon
which is also at the bottom of your
screen I believe unless YouTube has
changed it
uh since the last time I did this
and we have a very very special offer
for you
to celebrate the coronation of King
Charles the Third
we are giving you the chance to
subscribe to The Spectator and you will
get the next 10 weeks of the magazine
and all of our digital offerings for the
price of just one edition not only that
but we'll also send you a commemorative
spectator mug a coronation mug
absolutely free to claim this very
special offer go to
spectator.co.uk forward slash coronation
and I actually have uh one of these
commemorative coronation mugs right in
front of me here it is says The
Spectator on the back his majesty King
Charles III
uh and I'm going to pretend to drink
from it to show you how to use it just
in case anybody doesn't know how to use
a mug
here we go delicious lovely air
um do take up that offer it's an
absolute bargain
now let's start with the labor party
because the cover of The Spectator this
week is these Stormtroopers and it's
written by Katie Bulls are politics
editor and we are delighted to be joined
in Scotland uh down the line by Aisha
hazarinka uh and you are an ex-labor
advisor
um in your past are you not Asia but
more more well known now for being a
broadcaster and columnist
hello well it's lovely to be with you
from um my parents Attic in Glasgow
where where in Glasgow
and they live in Newton Marion's um in
Glasgow and so apologies for the
slightly weird setup of this shot it's a
bit like going back in time when you go
and see your parents so here we are it's
like a sort of Museum that I'm sitting
in right now well I think they're
probably a bit more high-tech than mine
uh but uh Katie let's start with you
because you wrote the piece
uh you say that uh Kirsten was Centrist
New Model Army is taking over the labor
party or has established control of
their party uh and the recruitment
process is ongoing
uh how Centrist is it is it wrong to
sort of call it a blairite takeover
they're right takeover but if you're
looking at the new intake of uh future
labor MPS these are the people being
picked to be candidates
um over a hundred candidates picked so
far lots of these are the key Target
seats and if you look at the polls right
now seem pretty winnable and given labor
are still quite far ahead on the Tories
I think it's fair to say it's more of a
Blair right takeover than a corporate
night one
um but I think if you look at the
candidates there's only one really that
could be described as Corbin sympathetic
um Shaheen who was a candidate the last
time around and uh instead when you're
looking at uh the type of people who are
being picked I think you know largely I
think fall into into two groups so one
is your I think your Blair out brown eye
restoration where you do have for
example Douglas Alexander former
minister in the labor government he has
the key Target seat of East Logan where
I am from
um and that is I think excuse one of the
most winnable seats in Scotland and you
also have four former Blair advisors you
have figures who were advisors during
the Blair government who are trying to
actually step out and join Frontline
politics this time around and you have
Labor princelings in the sense of um you
know Charlie Falconer you have his son
Hamish is going for a seat he's been
selected and that seat looks pretty
winnable and so so that's on one side
and then I think the other side of this
is uh candidates who I think are being
picked more for uh the their life
experience and then their long-time
commitment to the cause you know this
has created some upset because those on
the left of the party feel so uh you
know they're being shut out
um but also I think you know within they
but it is now the case that if you have
an interesting career so there's you
know former prison officers there's a
former SAS man and what does that bring
to the table in Parliament and I think
that some of these things are seen is
more important than being someone who
has put out leaflets for X number of
years and a large part of your piece is
very interesting because it's about how
rigorous the the selection process has
been because they want to sort of wheel
out the bad eggs and this is not just to
do with Corbin it's also looking at the
Tory party and how many disasters
they've had recently uh they're going
through people's social media feeds and
so on tell us a bit about that yes when
I was um earlier this week I was coming
into Westminster and I bumped into a
Tory advisor and it's really writing
about this week and I said I'm doing
Labor candidates said oh well yeah
they're right to be strict look at some
of the people we got in 2019
so I think this is a this is a problem
that both parties experience and when it
comes to selection of candidates
um it's not always that widely reported
because it can be quite techy but
clearly the type of people who become
the the MPS of Tomorrow are so important
to have Parliament is run the fact that
Boris Johnson yes won a majority of 80
but it hasn't really felt like that
you've had so many you know internal
divides and people who aren't you know
particularly loyal to the regime and so
forth so kisdom is trying to smooth that
out and as you say and vetting is a key
part of that because we've had two snap
elections
recent years that always means you have
much more you know it's fast track
candidate selection which means things
can slip through the net but I think
it's also the case in the labor party
um that you had a situation where uh
often you know some current labor MPS
complain that
um some of the candidates who are picked
were picked more because they were the
momentum candidate or they were close to
you know all they were seen as a Corbin
Ally then because they were actually
suitable and had vetting taken place
they might not pass the test if you
think about some recent MPS so you had
Jared omara uh the former labor MP for
Sheffield Harlem uh now obviously
sentenced on various kinds of fraud
um and you also have Claudia Webb a
former labor MP who also found herself
ending up in court
um so they're trying to avoid that and
also these negative stories about you
know anti-semitic posts and so forth I
think the question is no one thinks
vetting is a bad idea um and Kirsten
can't really afford the negative press
of you know more anti-Semitism stories
if you look at Diane Abbott this week
week but is it when does the vetting
start to be used as a as a means to pick
candidates slightly on your own image
and that's the complaint of someone
those on the left which is yes vetting
but they think it's not being applied in
an equal way and it's being used as a
way to stop some of their candidates
getting through uh Aisha um I suppose
the obvious question is what happens now
to the corbinite left uh obviously the
the key figure Jeremy corbyn is out the
picture he's been pushed out of the
labor tent now
um and Diane Abbott uh this week
disgraced for her uh slip in the
guardian uh are these figures now going
to form their own movement is there
going to be a divide in low body or has
kirst armor got enough momentum because
momentum being the choice well has he
got enough momentum of his own now to be
able to pull the party together in the
way he wants to pull it together
well I think the starting point with
this is an acknowledgment and a
recognition of how much internal
politics has gone on and how many
battles have been won internally sort of
away from the The Gaze of of the media
which has put king of starmer in this
position because when you look back to
where we were with Jeremy corbyn the
thing that made the Jeremy corbyn era so
difficult for many people who had fought
militant you know alongside Neil kinnick
was that never before in the labor party
did you have the hard left not just in
leadership positions but they controlled
the NEC they controlled the the
Machinery of the party and they largely
controlled
um the Parliamentary labor party as well
there was a huge influx of of of sort of
you know harder left um leaning MPS and
I think that's something that we gloss
over quite quickly when we talk about
the achievements of kyostarma I mean he
has done a lot of things behind the
scene I remember there was a conference
a couple of years ago where he
introduced some quite big rule changes
to try and win back control from the
hard left for example rules where
sitting MPS more Centrist MPS couldn't
have the threat of deselection from from
their um you know Trade Union affiliates
and and you know harder members in their
constituencies we saw that a lot
particularly with Jewish labor and
female MPS for example during the Corbin
years so I think it's a it's really
important to acknowledge how much work
has gone on behind the scenes you know
we talk a lot about Kia stormers policy
operation or his press operation but his
actual political operation behind the
scenes has been incredibly effective and
Incredibly ruthless so kyostarma is now
in that position where he does control
the party but it has been quite a long
and bloody battle behind the scenes
internally for him to be in that
position and I think having wrestle
wrestled back control from the hard left
internally he and his team particularly
on the really that the sort of nuts and
bolts political side of the operation
the people who do the organizing who
manage the regional organizing section
who leads with the trade unions and of
course who do the selections they are
really battle hardened because of the
the last you know couple of years and so
they are being very very hard line about
selections about who gets into the party
and I think that's the right thing to do
because of all the reasons that Katie um
cited I mean the the Sheffield MP
um Jared omara is an absolutely classic
example of what happens when you rush
people through I think Claudia Webb has
actually imposed on her seat
um in in Leicester so I think that the
the team around kyostarma on that
political side led by Morgan McSweeney
are being really really tough and I
think they make no apologies for that
and I think that's the right thing to do
I mean we I feel sometimes the media the
commentariat and you know a lot of
people you know around our business
slightly fall into a trap of complacency
that it is just written in the stars
that the labor party is going to win the
next general election that these
um you know substantial poll numbers
will just stick until the next general
election so the question now becomes
always curious armor becoming too
Centrist is he becoming you know too
boring because he's too focused on
winning an election which is in the bag
no nothing is in the bag yeah I was
speaking to a senior labor person the
other day their worry is that these pool
leads are in fact soft as butter you
have an example like the Diane Abba um
issue it raises the whole thing of
anti-Semitism again it's like it's a
massive kind of open goal for the labor
party and you just look at history there
is nothing
um that that suggests that labor is you
know predetermined to win any election I
remember back in 2015 myself you know we
were briefing out on the day of the
election
actually you know how long would we give
David Cameron the chance to squat in
number 10 before he'd be you know hoofed
out and actually it turned out it was a
Tory majority so absolutely nothing is
set in stone and I think that's why it's
right that the labor party has been
really really tough it's got to select
people who are good it's got to select
people who um could be good ministers as
well and it's got to you know select
people who are just not going to be
massive puddings like we have just had
you know completely non-impressive
people as MPS for a long time and that
is very much Katie said that is very
very true of
um the Tory party I thought was
interesting this week William Hague
wrote in the times that actually we
should think about that dirty word the e
word elitism returning to politics a bit
we should actually strive to have really
good interesting people in Parliament
who will not just be good constituency
MPS and that you know you should be a
good constituent MP but you can also
actually you know serve on a national
stage or an international stage as well
because you look at the quality of MPS
in this party from from both sides labor
and Tori of the last couple of intakes
and you think yeah this is not a
Pantheon of greets but by a long stretch
Katie I mean Alicia spells up very well
there how storm has established control
of the Party Machine and how important
that is and and how it's bigger than
just the machine it's about how politics
works but there is this question of you
know corbyn did excite a lot of young
voters uh there was Corbin Mania I think
it's fair to say there hasn't been
Stormer Mania and perhaps that's a good
thing in some ways not yet it's coming
uh but one that the the obvious question
again is what's going to happen to that
harder left if you like that that more
youthful uh radical element in the labor
party I mean what's happened to momentum
yeah I mean momentum still exists I
think it is uh you know a depleted Force
I think that's an interesting question
as you say which is
um
so when you're looking at these
candidates now I think I had one uh you
know labor old hand effectively say to
me they are there are plenty who seem
like they'll be good future Junior
ministers but do you have any Future
Leaders and obviously it's your hotel
but there is a risk
um that you you know that that if you
know certain factions uh feel as though
they are not being included you have you
know you don't have a cross you don't
have that mix of views
um which can uh you know excite and you
know appeal to different voters I think
when you look at what Kazama has done
wholesale as you say you're not getting
um you know Corbin Mania though of
course Corvin media did calm down I
remember going to labor live uh that
music festival
um which by that point I think they
thought would be the Glastonbury pyramid
stage moment that Corbin had and with
all those chants and actually turned out
to be uh I think a disaster financially
and then quite a quiet Affair so it
might feel like the Tory Woodstock yeah
yeah yeah we did they had the George
Freeman Festival didn't we as well and
also not a huge uh huge sense of
momentum of that one um but yeah so I
think um so I think these things can be
fleeting but I think there is a question
which is
given kissed armor and those around them
are taking the strategy of almost a
safety first strategy I would argue and
uh lots of people are saying you know
well what's the difference in the
literary and there are lots of
differences but you have a situation
where the attack ads for example where
you know some of the the labor party
shouldn't be you know doing this as one
of the Tories that's below the labor
party uh you know to be to be loose with
the truth
um is there a point when some of the
younger base who do not look at kissed
armor and see perhaps a labor party that
they liked under something like Jeremy
corbyn go to the greens oh are you going
to have such a desire to get the Tories
out amongst those um different voters
that you could actually you can actually
take the bat that trying to appeal to
some of these for example red wall
voters and is more important because
you're going to keep the others with you
I think it's interesting how far they
can push that because it does feel so
quite a few things recently
um you know and not the ones that are
appealing to to those who who would look
to Jeremy corbyn but are they going to
go anywhere else
you should we had another resignation
today Emma Dent code uh uh resigned
um we think probably because of this
what's going on with starmer and Diane
Abbott and so on uh again I don't want
to sort of push on the labor crack-up
point but I think it's worth exploring
if uh the people who've been pushed
outside the tent decide to form a
movement what sort of threat could it
pose to starmer
well I think if there is a lot of chat
on on that end of the party about you
know should you stay and fight which of
course what is what many centrists did
um during the the Jeremy corbyn years
and you could argue as Katie does in her
brilliant piece that um you know the
centrists are now sort of on top but I
think the truth is for the foreseeable
future the the centrists are going to
dominate the the party and I think many
people on the sort of harder left of the
party remember a lot of these people
joined very fleetingly because of Corbin
Mania they had always voted for other
parties they had in fact been involved
in other parties which had stood against
the labor party many of these people who
came into the party as part of the
Corman Corbin Mania they didn't actually
have like a huge lifelong affiliation
with the labor party some did but a lot
didn't they were quite transient in
terms of their sort of adoration for for
this you know Jeremy corbyn sort of Buzz
that that Sean bright for a bit 2017 but
let's be honest very much crashed and
burned when the labor party got totally
spanked in
2019 but I think in terms of what what
they do there's not a huge amount that
they can do it's interesting to see John
McDonald
um make some comments this week he sort
of seems to be the last member of the
Old Guard and the corbyn leadership who
hasn't had the whip removed and he's
quite careful what what he says um about
the the leadership and he's trying to
offer some sort of constructive advice
look if I'm being charitable
about that wing of the party what I do
have some sympathy with is that you know
labor
always I think is at its best when it's
a bit of a broad church but you have
sensible people in in charge you know
under Tony Blair's time you know Tony
Blair whatever you think of him was the
sort of most successful labor leader
that the party has ever had you know you
you still did have um a lot of people on
the left within the movement
um you know shouting at him at various
conferences and you have people on the
left in terms of the Trade union
movement and those people were always a
bit of a thorn in the side of of of of
Tony Blair's um government but many of
his political teams said look it is
important to have this broad church but
that was also because Tony Blair was in
in Paris he had like delivered the goods
in terms of what the political well the
political party is meant to do as in his
one power where I suppose like there is
an argument there are some people who
are concerned
that if everybody is a sort of cookie
cutter kyostarma you know are you going
to is everything going to be then be
quite Bland and you know are you going
to sort of excite people
and I I think that is you know that
isn't an argument and I hear it a lot
Jonas like Michael Crick for example
make that argument about the the
selection process I suppose the
Counterpoint would be that the labor
party has had so much excitement over
the last couple of years we've had so
much excitement including losing
elections really really badly and sort
of falling apart at the seams so to
Katie's point I think starma's team
knows that there's a trade-off there's a
trade-off between being exciting and
slightly thrilling and sort of you know
edgy or the other side is the kind of
take a safety first approach the the
analogy about the Ming vars being
carried across the the polished floor
and take a safety first approach because
the labor party has not been this close
and we're a long way out from a general
election but in terms of the polls it
hasn't really been this close to winning
power for a very very long time so they
just don't want to to risk it I suppose
what they will have to do I I think
most people out there looking at at the
labor party right now are probably not
saying gosh the candidates are a bit
dull like they probably don't know
anything about the candidates they don't
really know much about the shadow
cabinet to be honest they sort of know
two three people they know Kia St Arma
they know a little bit about Rachel
Reeves they know a tiny wee bit about
where streeting they knew Ed Miller Band
from ages go that's sort of like the
four people they kind of know in in the
shadow cabinet a lot of the excitingness
is going to become down from from Kia
the sort of thrill and the vision and
The Surge of excitement is not going to
come from oh look who we've you know
selected in Derby North it's going to be
Kia stama closer to the election coming
out with more flesh on the bone and that
is an argument that I think is valid a
lot of people are saying well look we're
now possibly a year out from the
election we've had these five missions
we're not quite sure what they mean we
do need to see more flesh on the boom
Katie the thrill of care
I saw you I saw you rustling when when
with excitement yeah quivering with
excitement I mean we're waiting for the
thrill of care and I think but yeah um
yet to yet to go um commercial or mass
market with the frill I think
um but I think taisha's Point uh you
have when you're looking at part of the
reason the candidate selection is so
strict is that they don't know what type
of Victory or even defeat the labor
party is going to the next election so
if you are John McDonnell
it is possible that labor went over a
majority of two then all of a sudden if
you're a mp on the left of the labor
party who has managed not to have the
whip suspended a a number a group that's
depleting by the day at the moment and
then you suddenly have a lot of power if
you think about um having a voice search
so you never quite know how things are
going to land and I think that's why uh
you know speaking to senior figures in
the labor party said well the point is
we they obviously stressed that they're
not being complaced and it's their
favorite thing to say but they said even
if we don't win the point is these
selections mean we have already won in
some ways in terms of changing the
Parliamentary labor party and that means
if you end up a hung Parliament a small
Tory majority they think the parties
will be in a much better place in terms
of um you know harder for it to Veer
back to what happened in 2015 with
Jeremy corbyn and and that should mean
it isn't a better place to gain power
even if it doesn't happen the next time
around
Aisha thank you very much for joining
spectator TV and thank you Katie too
now a brutal conflict has broken out
again in Sudan in Khartoum in recent
days and the big media story here has
been understandably how do we get uh
British citizens out of there and the
government's various efforts to evacuate
British possible holders and British
workers from Sudan however a lot of
people are also interested in how this
conflict began and the various
complicated dynamics of Sudan which have
largely been overlooked in recent years
so I'm delighted to be joined by Dr
Chirino hitang ofuo who is a former
minister in the south of Sudan and he's
joining us now from Kenya Dr Chirino
thank you very much for joining us
most welcome
um well let's start uh with this latest
eruption of violence how did we get here
how did this conflict start give our
viewers a little history of what's going
on
thank you uh in fact this is the most
unfortunate uh event in recent history
that uh a war just broke out
unexpectedly because uh however the
crisis have been going on there have
been a lot of differences between the
rsf and uh and the Sudanese Army uh or
since the the fall of albashir and uh
they are as eventually uh emerged as a
force that was coming to stabilize the
aftermath of the series collapse from
power and uh unfortunately the rsf
became a prevailing and dominant
military force in in in Khartoum and
particularly within the center of power
in uh in in her tomb uh first uh there
was a cooperation between uh burhan
president
eventually because they work together in
the pool for over many years and so
people
so that as maybe something that can
bring good working relationship between
the two unfortunately for ideological
reasons disciple fell out particularly
when they took over power from the from
the civilian rule under prime minister
hamdock
in short really it was never expected
that this brutal rule could could happen
between burhan and hemeti and rightly so
because behind it really which many
people do not see and do not know and
maybe by now they have known is behind
this is actually the islamist
the islamists who were under albashir
the the the national Islamic front and
they are still there they were
hibernating behind and and they took
advantage of this and triggered the the
crisis between uh bruhan and uh and and
hemetic and this is where uh uh many
people are shocked attacking by shock
particularly Sudanese themselves those
the experts who know the Sudanese
politics Will really find out that this
was totally something that came up like
that struck like lightning between the
two but it is held the islamists who
were behind it who want to come back to
Power in the in in the Sudan who are
very upset with uh with the emergency
and particle of the rsf and that's why
they reverted them as a militia uh and
they don't really look at them as a
military uh Force like the Sudanese Army
who are very proud uh military who look
at themselves as an army a strong Army
in the country that fought many wars
that was able to defend the country
against uh the splm John garang's Sudan
people's Liberation movements Liberation
Army a very strong Army that built over
20 years that they resisted that and
they were able to stand and uh until
they signed peace and the South broke
out
well the um the the rasf uh we
understand grew out of the janjaweed who
uh did become internationally recognized
a few years ago because they were
terrorizing particularly Christians in
the south of Sudan
um
how uh is it correct to see the rsf the
rapid support forces as uh the more
vicious islamist uh faction
actually the you're right there because
they are actual islamists they were they
were they were initially playing as
islamists they actually is very thin
line of difference between the rsf and
then and and and and the Islam is now
who want to take over power back uh in
sudanja up to now including hemeti who
are still uh sanctioned by the
International Community because of the
atrocities they committed in Darfur in
fact nobody even expected uh the others
have to be legitimized as the way it
happened after the kids collapse from
power and uh and the the little
difference between the two I think it
has to do with the the tradition of how
the Sudanese Army have been trained uh
conventionally and they look at
themselves as a as a conventional Army
unlike the RSL who who are always
referred to as uh as as as paramilitary
meaning that that they are not really
the same as the Sudanese Army and and I
can agree with you that I think that the
difference are
very thin between the rsf when it comes
to Islamic ideology
and an oddity of of this conflict has
been that it's broken out during the end
of Ramadan which is meant to be a time
of peace and reflection absolutely in
fact on a Friday I I'm told on the 14th
on a Friday they had a dinner and uh one
of the leaders of the of the transient
council is uh General Malik agar who is
the leader from Blue Nile who was
organizing to mediate between hemeti and
and burhan and really they did not
expect this crisis to to break out
especially during Ramadan it was still
shocking even to people like you know
Malik agar he never expected that this
war was going to happen because he was
one of the mediators and uh he he has
always tried to play this role of being
a moderate and and and having the stlm
sbla background and now one of the
leaders of the skeleminos so Malik was
not really Keen to see this kind of of
of Crisis unfolding
and how do people in the South you're
from the south how do people in the
South feel about this uh conflict
between what seems to be a rival uh
Islamic or islamist groups in the North
this is a very interesting question
because actually many people in the
South are divided there are many who are
sympathetic to the situation but also
sizable majority who have never forgiven
the north but what they did to
themselves have said okay let them test
the salt of wood they have always
imposed on the south it is uh it is
unfortunate that many Southerners of
that nature could could look like let us
see the north boil into this because
they have always put us in the South
under similar circumstances but the
majority of of Southerners also who are
totally much who probably spend a lot of
their time growing and doing a lot of
business or having gone to schools in
the north real feel the sympathy of what
has happened but otherwise there are
others in the South Who Says Yes
it for over 50 years the South has been
subjected uh by by by Northern Sudanese
Elites under similar circumstances
and what about the involvement of uh
outside Powers uh I mean I think in the
west uh there was a lot of
concern about Darfur but perhaps we
turned our attention away from it
because it seemed to have settled down
there seemed to be some sort of
political
um settlement and now there's a lot of
talk in in Western media about the role
of Russia
um because of uh I think the Wilder
group seeming to have some connection
with the Russian mercenary group seeming
to have some connection with the rsf
um
is this a case of Russia and the West
sort of squabbling for power or is it
more complicated than that no I think
okay I think there has been uh of course
that Scramble for Africa they call it
now maybe you call it as another
struggle Scramble for Africa where
Russia versus the West uh
have been uh seen uh playing different
roles but I think uh there has been a
larger involvement of uh of the rsf
leader particular hemeti with uh with
Russia and with other Middle East Powers
mainly based on his engagement in
business in trade he is is a very big
businessman
has become the center of attention
required by Russia and he is a
connection even with the Wagner group as
we as as we have all seen now is no
secret and uh so hamiti has really had a
lot of business with uh with Russia
other than uh the West like uh Britain
or the United States of America
you mentioned gold uh Sudan is a very
resource-rich country uh obviously this
is a very another troubling phase for it
but what do you think is a is an
optimistic scenario for the future how
could this be settled
this uh this situation in the Sudan is
really very very volatile and I think
that uh many people never expected it as
I said it before and uh the the attitude
of the leaders now if you look at
they have just signed this Armitage
these truth just for to allow the
evacuation of uh foreigners from Sudan
but they are not giving room they have
never given any signal for giving room
for any talks or any negotiations so for
some of us an analyst who know uh
similar conflicts we we I'm very worried
that it could turn out like a Yemen or
Syria
um
so I'm actually impressed also by the
response of the West uh particularly
Britain and the United States of America
and particularly Britain for that matter
having been the the colonial power upon
Sudan and uh and and a government that
has Associated itself with Sudan for a
long time that they have responded quite
uh uh very fast and and putting large
attention and you hear uh British
foreign secretary the U.S Secretary of
State all at least on daily basis have
given a lot of their time to this and I
think that's uh an impressive part from
that perspective
Dr turiano thank you very much for
coming on to spectator TV
to turn to America where on Tuesday
President Joe Biden announced that he
would be running for re-election in the
presidential election next year this
surprised nobody um we even told you
spectator back in January on our cover
that this was going to happen
and I think it's also fair to say that
it hasn't really excited anybody as well
I'm joined Now by Grace Curley who is
host of The Grace curly show
um Grace A lot of people are talking
about this but it's worth reflecting on
a majority of Democrats don't want Joe
Biden to run
um a huge majority of young Democrats
don't want um Joe Biden to run I think
something like 76 of 18 to 34 year olds
don't think he should run
um and yet here we are we're approaching
um and he's going to run why
I think he's going to run I was thinking
about it over the weekend because almost
the opposite reasons why Trump is
running so Trump has a lot of enthusiasm
with voters people really
um they feel connected to Trump they
feel this loyalty to Trump with Biden
it's the opposite so I think with Biden
it's the establishment who's very happy
with his performance they like having
somebody who's really just kind of a
puppet who they can pull the strings you
know he's not going to fight back he's
not going to give them a hard time he
really doesn't know what's going on and
so they like having that person in there
who they can boss around now as you said
the enthusiasm from voters might not be
there but the establishment and and the
swamp really as far as Democrats go who
are in charge they don't care they don't
care if the voters they know the voters
will vote for him I mean that's the big
difference here there's a difference
between
lacking enthusiasm and people not
actually going out and voting for you
and I just because Democrats aren't
excited about him I don't think they're
they're going to uh not
vote for him can you be precise
particularly for mostly British viewers
we think uh what is the establishment in
America what is the swamp who are these
people who have decided that Joe Biden
is it not Joe Biden has decided that Joe
Biden is going to run again
no I think that there's a lot of you
know power players in the Democrat Party
a lot of like Senator Chuck Schumer and
then you have these Congress people who
have a lot of power on social media I
think they have a big sway in what
actually happens in DC and so that's
what I mean when I say The Establishment
I mean people surrounding Joe Biden who
are the decision makers because I don't
think he's a decision maker and I think
if and probably you know what probably
there's a mix two of
the media is involved as well because I
think if the media had wanted to
and they had softened the soil a little
bit going into this they could have
taken Joe Biden down with his scandals
but they covered for him and so I think
a combination of Joe's colleagues in DC
and also the media kind of running cover
for him have allowed him to seek another
term as president
and what it leaves us with is a
situation where the majority I mean Joe
Biden and indeed Hillary Clinton did win
a popular majority let's not get into
the specifics of the both of those
elections but uh the majority of people
who have voted Democrat in the past are
left with a candidate
um who they don't like I don't know if
you know the comedian Bo Burnham but he
had a very good song called Joe Biden
where he sang they're really going to
make me vote for Joe Biden that was back
in 2020 uh it's going to be exactly the
same thing in 2024. and uh a lot of
people I've done a piece about it myself
this week are thinking this speaks to
some great dysfunction in American
democracy that unpopular presidents just
carry on
what do you think about that
yeah
I guess it's just kind of sad like I was
thinking about that as well I mean 2020
we had we're probably gonna have the
exact same matchup and uh it's
it kind of shows it's it's very
uninspiring to put it mildly and I
understand why young voters are
frustrated too because they're a lot of
these young Democrats are very radical
they're very Progressive and there's
plenty of people who are kind of
climbing the ranks who have been dying
to have the torch passed to them but I
think what
there was a really good piece by Victor
I think it was Victor Davis Hanson in
American greatness and he kind of wrote
about how
it's a good way when you have these
older Democrats who a lot of younger
people would consider boring and you
know past their Prime
not to I don't want to Don Lemon myself
I just mean you know they're in their
80s
um it's a nice way for Democrats to be
able to put up this front that we're old
school look at you know we still kind of
are catering to the center you know
middle of the road Democrat even if
they're not so I think that that's a
part of it too which the young people
probably it frustrates them but it is a
smart Play Because as much as they want
a younger person in there who's just
going to tell it like it is and really
tell the voters exactly what they want
to hear you're better off with the Joe
Biden who can at least pretend to be
this old grandfather you know who's
working across the aisle and used to get
a beer with people who are conservatives
and
that kind of cover for Democrats
actually works in their favor
an interesting element is Joe Biden's
vice president who is of course Kamala
Harris who as everybody probably knows
by now is even less popular than Joe
Biden uh and has widely seen to be a
fairly inept Veep uh there is some
speculation that Biden could drop her
um and pick a more
um exciting or uh successful or
inspiring candidate for 2024
um which might uh address some of the
concerns about his second term because
if if uh if he's going to be 86 by the
time he finishes his second term if his
health Fades even more
you may get a situation where the vice
president has to step up and become the
president so who he chooses if he drops
Kamala Harris uh will become very very
important do you think it's possible or
likely that he will drop Kamala Harris
and who might he choose
no I don't think it's possible I never
thought it was possible even even when
the rumbling started I just don't think
there's any way that you can do that
without really upsetting like a lot of
those voters we just talked about they
might not be excited about Kamal Harris
they might not love her but they love
getting mad about things they love being
offended they love you know outrage and
um giving Kamala Harris the boot would
definitely cause a lot of
um
frustration and anger and I've I've read
things before about people saying like
oh you know he could just he could pick
another black woman to come in there's
you know because there's so many
um and I'm not denying that that there's
plenty of candidates
but that to me seems really
um like he's just using people at that
point if you're just taking one person
and swapping them out for another and
you think that uh these black women are
interchangeable that to me seems like a
really dangerous road to go down and if
I were Kamala Harris or any of her fans
she might not have a lot of fans but I
would be offended I I would I would take
that as a huge insult so I don't think
he's gonna go near that I think he's
just gonna they're gonna play the same
the same thing they did in 2020 it
worked so why mess with a good thing I
guess
you said that you think uh the
Republican nominee who the person who
Joe Biden will probably face next year
is probably going to be Donald Trump uh
We've taught the Forum spectator TV
we've covered it quite a lot in the
magazine uh about Governor Ron DeSantis
the governor of Florida
um
obviously Trump has this very
significant lead in the polls quite how
much we can read into the polls at this
early stage is a matter of debate
um do you think Ron DeSantis chances of
being underrated at the moment or
overrated
I think underrated I think the fact that
he hasn't even officially thrown his hat
in the ring yet he hasn't really given
us his 100 attempt at this I wouldn't
count him out I think we still have a
long way to go I mean people forget in
2016 before those debates it the the
landscape the field was totally
different nobody had Donald Trump on
their bingo card so a lot can change
when you start to see these candidates
interact and America gets a real look at
who their who they're potentially
picking
um I I think that
there is this Rush from Republicans to
just choose and have it done with and
you know it's it's Trump and there's no
other way to go but I kind of think
we're doing ourselves a disservice and
I'm honest I'm a conservative so if
anyone out there I'm fully Republican so
I I just think that where
um
we're eliminating our options very early
and I don't think that's a smart
strategic move
uh the census is sort of Ace card if you
like would be Trump fatigue
um that a lot of Voters uh are fed up of
all the drama about Trump they they look
they may like him they may even love him
but they may think uh we've been beaten
uh three times in a row arguably
Nationwide in the midterms in 2018 in
the presidential in 2020 in the midterms
again in 2022
um and it makes more sense to move on
do you have Trump fatigue Grace curly
and do you think you're the audience of
your show has Trump fatigue
to my show definitely does not have
Trump fatigue
through waves of it you know especially
over the last couple of months where you
have things like you have the raid at
Mar-A-Lago you have the Trump indictment
I mean you have these moments where your
Trump fatigue gets overwhelmed by your
sense of outrage about what's happening
to them so then you kind of go back into
feeling like this guy's getting screwed
I'm rooting for him and so I've kind of
fluctuated between the truth between the
two my audience has not my audience is
most for the most part very much team
Trump
um but yeah I think this is what we keep
hearing from a lot of people is DeSantis
could be Trump without all the baggage
now what then I hear if you bring that
up from
Trump Republicans is well you're so
naive if you don't think they're going
to go after DeSantis in the same way
they've gone after Donald Trump and what
I always respond to that is I am not
stupid I know they're going to go after
DeSantis they've already tried multiple
times with these crazy stories about him
what I think it comes down to is who can
handle that better and who can kind of
not get distracted by that as much and
that's where I think desantis's appeal
lies is that he has an ability to not
get too sucked in to a lot of these
small fights and small arguments yes
well one uh potentially very big fight
is on the issue of abortion
um because of Donald Trump and because
of the justices he put on the Supreme
Court uh last summer we had the Dobbs
decision which overturned Roe v Wade and
the legal right to the federal right to
an abortion in America and yet since
that's happened abortion has sort of
flipped as an issue and become a big big
winner or a bigger winner than it was
for the Democrats in a way that is
alarms Republican strategist because
you're seeing a lot of progressive women
and young people going out and voting in
ways they didn't before for the
Democrats because they want to stop the
republican-led challenge to abortion Ron
DeSantis recently signed a six-week Bill
uh sorry Banning a ban on abortions
after six weeks in Florida
and Trump has been strangely muted on
abortion of late and in fact in I think
his latest statement on it he said this
is rightly a state's issue
um how is that going to play out on the
Republican side
it almost reminds what Trump is doing
with DeSantis kind of reminds me of what
a lot of Republicans oh I'm sorry a lot
of Democrats do with Donald Trump where
they get so focused on the person that
their policies change based off what he
does and so if he reverses course then
Democrats tend to want to do the
opposite of whatever he's doing I think
DeSantis is kind of having that effect
on Trump where he wants to be against
DeSantis so he's changing a lot of the
things that he's been saying over the
last couple of years
um this this issue though is so tricky
and I I saw today that Nikki Haley said
that you know the country needs to come
to a consensus on abortion and she
thinks she knows how to do it and I just
don't understand how that happens like I
don't
I don't see how
because I I've been seeing Democrats and
Republicans saying well you know if if
these candidates could just kind of move
to the center and change their stances a
little bit then they might win over
voters
and that's fine if you're a candidate
who really doesn't believe what you're
saying and there are people who feel in
the middle about abortion I'm kind of
one of those people I don't tend to have
a super strong opinion but if you are a
republican who has a strong belief that
abortion is killing an unborn human
then how do you move to the middle on
that like how do you how do you convince
someone to kind of just abandon that for
the sake of you know widening the tent
and I'm not trying to sound holier than
now I'm just saying I I don't I don't
see how we can come to a consensus on
something that for a lot of people in
this country is black and white one way
or the other
uh Donald Trump
does win the nomination do you think he
will has a better chance of beating Joe
Biden than Ron DeSantis would
no no I don't
um
I I think
if I were really to guess I would say
Ron DeSantis probably has a better
chance of beating Joe Biden because
there's a lot of people who um I I guess
it's I don't think the left will be able
to
kind of gin up the same hatred for Ron
DeSantis in the short amount of time as
they did for Donald Trump that to me
feels like lightning in a bottle that
kind of trump derangement syndrome is
going to be hard to duplicate with
somebody else and it's going to be hard
for the media to tell people oh this
guy's actually worse than Donald Trump
you thought Trump was bad we told you
Trump was a dictator but this new guy
who seems to be a family man and he's
pretty low-key and he doesn't go on
Twitter a lot he's actually worse than
Trump I just think there's a lot of
people in the center who aren't going to
buy that and so I think that the
combination of that and the fact that
DeSantis is a lot younger and he could
really showcase that on the debate stage
against Joe Biden I think that's that's
a win in his column I think the polls so
far as to who would win in a matchup
DeSantis Biden or Trump Biden are quite
mixed at the moment
um but probably the reason why Trump
might have more of an advantage is that
he has always been able to drive out low
propensity voters
um and because of his name recognition
because of the people that a lot of
people the fact that a lot of people who
don't normally vote do vote for him and
I suppose there is doubts about whether
DeSantis would be able to do that what
do you think about that
yeah I think that's valid and and I
think that
this is why you have to have a primary
and you have to kind of keep an open
mind like I keep trying to remind people
there's nothing wrong with wanting to
see people actually
debate things in a primary and decide
who you like after watching all of the
candidates and for example I like Ron
DeSantis I have no idea if he could
handle questions on foreign policy I
mean there's a whole
there's a whole section of things that
he hasn't really had to tackle as the
governor of Florida so that would be
good to that'd be good to know it'd be
good to know where he stands on a lot of
these issues and it would be good to
hear him respond to a lot of these
criticisms from Donald Trump and you
know voice whether or not they're even
valid to begin with but that whole
process I'm noticing Americans have a
lot less patience for now people people
don't seem to want that at all so
they've already kind of chosen their
sides in a lot of these cases
great so I think we'll end it there but
uh I should say um because obvious
probably won't be able to spot it but
you are eight months pregnant so uh the
next time you come on spectator TV uh
you will have a baby uh I well I don't
know we may have you on sooner who knows
um but uh all the best with everything
and very nice to see you
finally let's talk about Hamlet Robert
golangton who is the third critic for
the Daily Mail has a very interesting
Arts lead in The Spectator this week
about uh it's about a new play really
which is called the motive and the queue
and it's about a very famous production
of Hamlet which starred Richard Burton
and was directed by John gilgood
um Robert joins me now along with Sean
Matthias who is a director and who
directed I believe Ian McKellen in
Hamlet is that right Sean it is right
yeah
uh and both on fiddleman on stage I
should say that's right just to be
released this later this year oh very
exciting uh Robert I'll start with you
because you wrote the piece
um this production uh was booze booze
adult uh as you say in the piece um it
was fraught and disastrous but was also
a Triumph and that's why there's now a
play about it can you explain a little
bit
well uh yes I mean John gilgood
um had uh got to know Burton a little
bit
um and it was suggested to him I think
that he might want to do um a play
celebrating Shakespeare's quarter
Centenary it was in 1964. and the two
actors came to the two actors came
together and
um uh and it just took off the idea um
was floated that they would do it in
America Burton had just
um was in the middle of divorcing his
wife Sybil they'd he'd been working with
Liz Taylor on Cleopatra and it was mired
in Scandal
um and I think what John gilgood didn't
realize was just what a road show the
whole uh Liz and Dick
um American thing was that they were
superstars no one could quite work out
which was the biggest star and um and
gilgood found himself at directing
Burton
um and I think in the end trying to get
from Burton uh the Hamlet that gilgood
gave and not really succeeding
Sean uh there have been obviously many
very famous performances of Hamlet do
you think Burton was the greatest or if
not who who was better
well unfortunately of course I I didn't
get to see I never saw Burton on stage I
it's a great one no I'm not very few of
us did um we're too young
but I'm live bird and I'm a fellow
Welshman and so of course I'm a great
fan of that voice and his screen
presence
um was astonishing and people who saw
him on stage everyone says it's a a
great great shame that he didn't go on
to have a stage career because he was a
wonderful stage actor
um actually I lie I did see him I saw
him and Liz do private lives all those
years later that was absolutely Dreadful
so and unfortunately it was a very bad
uh version of that amazing play but um
I mean he should have be there are so
many reasons why he could have been a
the most wonderful hamlet in Robert says
in his very excellent piece of really
good read makes him want to go and see
the play Robert says that gilgood said
um he didn't have the bearing of a
prince
I I think in contemporary terms that
that sort of slightly irrelevant because
the the one the thing about Hamlet that
everyone says he's changed the Hamlet we
meet the audience meets is not the
Hamlet he was before his father died so
his bearing could have changed
considerably he's not he doesn't behave
like a prince at any point during the
play so I I would have loved to have
seen Burton and um isn't it isn't it
amazing it was critically such a flop
but such a huge commit maybe the most
commercially successful Shakespeare
that's ever been staged
but why was it why was it so successful
is it because uh you know the the the
the nature of hablit uh the romantic
interest that there is in the hamlet uh
lends itself to a sort of tragic
disastrous production
no I I don't think that's right I think
what it was was that Burton uh was just
waiting everybody was so excited that
about Burton's voice apart from anything
else that he would be the inheritor of
gilgood in a way that it was a new voice
a working-class voice a Welsh voice
um and I think it generated enormous
interest the real problem as I and I
didn't see it either I mean and nobody's
seen it now and you can't even see it
there was a recording and you can't even
see that because Burton had them all
destroyed but the real problem I think
from a um from gilga's point of view was
that he was an alcoholic and he was
completely unreliable in her rehearsals
um he had a disease and I mean it must
have been a nightmare we don't know but
I mean he was well into probably two two
bottles of okra a day by then and I
think I think the whole thing was a
Triumph for Burton just for getting
through it but I think Gil couldn't
contain him couldn't really get what he
wanted from him
um and and it became this course celeb
and of course the fans just wanted to be
around Burton and Liz Taylor
so the whole thing got completely caught
up in a sort of different Road Show I
think
Sean presumably you didn't have uh
similar problems with Ian mcgillen we
didn't have problems with Ian but we had
we were we were fraught with uh troubles
I mean first of all of course when as we
were right before moments before we were
going into rehearsal the pandemic hit
and the first lockdown said so we were
postponed for a long time we did
Workshop that played Hackney Empire in
the middle of that first pandemic summer
but we still couldn't go into the
theater so I came up with this idea of
making a movie which was not a film
version of The Stage production because
we hadn't done the Stage production but
in actual films I came up with a
treatment and the entire film is set
within the theater Royal Windsor Theater
Royal Windsor becomes Elsinore if you
like because we had the great uh a good
luck that bill can write the producer
owns that theater so we were able to go
in there and film but we were fraught
with problems during filming and people
left people walked out people were in
high Dodge and a lot of people were in a
great state of uh neuroses and and
disturbance because of the pandemic
because of being locked down because of
being confused and then we finally came
to do it on stage and again we were from
with problems our Laertes left us before
the first preview and McAllen had to
rehearse the whole fight scenes with an
understudy on the very first day we went
in front of an audience he did that aged
82 or something ludicrous but then it
was my crazy idea to cast an 80 year old
as Hamlet
um and uh actually I I'm very proud of
the film it's I think it's terrific and
the the show went very well people
because of Ian's Fame people came from
all over to see it but it's it's
interesting my idea was that anyone can
play anything it's it's theater theater
is fantasy it's part of the imagination
wouldn't it be great to hear a man who
spent his whole life saying Shakespeare
publicly
say those words of a young man because
psychologically it's such a an
extraordinary play I mean Shakespeare
was was used in the audience in a
Freudian or jungian way when nobody did
ever even thought you know hundreds of
years before therapy came about so the
the actual thought process that Hamlet
is going through and shares with the
audience is so it's it's it's such an
incredible challenge for any young actor
I remember Ben Whistle was only about 19
when he played it he brought such an
incredible dark
really dark and melancholic side to
Hamlet David Tennant who was was older
but still a young man brought out all
the irony you know so and Jonathan price
did with Richard there did that
incredible Hamlet where they um they
they used the idea from The Exorcist of
Hamlet being Hamlet's ghost being
literally inside Hamlet and Jonathan
price body contorting in sort of you
think he was going to vomit all over the
stage in anxiety and that that brought
the the ghost story made the ghost story
more relevant for a modern audience so
there are so many different
interpretations of the Hamlet
is that uh Robert is that why you think
the the that Hamlet has has been so
popular in in modernity is this
psychological element and the fact that
there are there are plays within plays
and you know there's been various
spin-off plays this is obviously one of
them uh you've got Rosen Cranston
Gilbertson are dead uh being probably
the most famous other one
um is that why the Arts world or the
modern arts world is so drawn to it
because of this the psychological
tensions uh I mean I I think I think
you're right and what Sean was saying is
all these different people bring
different things to Hamlet and and in a
way you never really play Hamlet you
play an aspect of him and so all of
those actors he mentioned brought
something new to the table and the
reason I think it persists this plague
is that it's it has this amazing ability
um to reflect the current times and and
it has this extraordinary
um your seeing a completely modern mind
well not completely modern but there he
is it's almost as though he knows he's
in a play and what I love I'm I'm I'd be
very interested to see if this comes out
in this new play about Burton is how how
much
um of Shakespeare they bring into the
rehearsal room I think it's a great sort
of challenge for an actor in a way that
perhaps Lea is a very different thing
but he has his freshness of mind and
he's so philosophical and it all sounds
so present when you hear it in a good
performance anyway
Sean do you think we could I mean
obviously Hamlet we're talking about
Hamlet here but do you think that could
be said of uh many Shakespeare plays I
mean Corey Elena's uh is one that has a
lot of modern interest uh Macbeth always
has uh interest do the the best
Shakespeare players just always adapt
themselves to the to the age that we're
in because they're so deep and so rich
well I mean he's certainly probably well
actually he's the most performed
playwright that ever was and probably
ever will be and not just in the English
language because it is open to Great
interpretation but I I don't think you'd
you'd call Shakespeare on the whole a
psychological writer although he's an
amazing Observer of people the play is
even you know Macbeth and which is a
very dark play of uh of trouble about
the troubled mind but most of those most
of his plays are driven by these
extraordinary plots and events and
actions Hamlet is not Hamlet is totally
the play is totally driven by inaction
of the man he absolutely can't he just
can't make his mind up he he can't he
he's he he's in a terrible state from
the beginning because he can't
understand why his mother has remarried
so quickly after his father's death and
then he's plunged into this other level
of Despair which is harder for a modern
audience is that he sees a ghost is the
ghost good or bad should he listen to
The Ghost and this goes on the the
subplot which is often erased and we
took a lot we cut a lot we cut it down
to just about the movies about one hour
and 50 minutes but we cut the play down
to 20 minutes but the subplot of Fordham
brass which we did reduce greatly is
very important because there is this
alternative Prince from an alternative
land that they're trying to be
diplomatic with allowing the forces to
March uh allowing the the the the
Norwegian forces to march across Denmark
and this Prince fought in brass has no
problem with action with mounting a huge
Army and taking huge risks Hamlet is
spurred on by that he really is spurred
on by that because he sees that directly
before they ship him to England and on
that boat to England he starts to become
the man of action and he comes back as a
man of action so I don't know that any
other Shakespeare's plays is quite so
psychological in that it deals with
thought you are you are literally the
actor playing Hamlet is sharing his
darkest deepest most confused most
complex Thoughts with an audience I
think that might be I think that's rare
in Shakespeare
it's a bit more interesting than William
and Harry isn't it
I think we better end it there but
Robert and Sean thank you very much for
coming on to spectator TV
that's all we've got time for this week
on spectator TV I hope you've enjoyed it
all thank you very much for watching a
reminder to subscribe to our YouTube
channel if you possibly can you do that
by clicking the Subscribe button at the
bottom of your screen and the famous
Bell icon
for just five pounds 75 you will get 10
weeks of The Spectator
not absolutely free it's 5.75 as I've
already said uh but you will also get
this mug that you may have noticed me
drinking from very subtly
um it's the spectator's special
correlation mug and it's very beautiful
thing too uh we will send you that
to celebrate the fact that you've taken
up a subscription to The Spectator as if
that needed any added incentive
thank you very much for watching
spectator TV please tune in again next
time
[Music]